many syrian refugees come to the densely
packed buildings of the jordanian
capital amman seeking refuge from the
bloody civil war raging in their own
country
jordan has long been a destination for
those escaping violence in neighboring
countries
over the years palestinians and iraqis
have flocked here now it's mainly
syrians who are coming
an estimated 750 000 of them
around two-thirds live outside refugee
camps many of them in oman
hospitality is part of jordanian culture
but the refugees are a topic of
discussion
we must take them she says where else
can they go
every country has good people and bad so
they're welcome here but well some are
nice and some aren't
the refugees have caused all sorts of
problems says this man from traffic to
housing and everything's more expensive
second
we want to find out what challenges are
facing syrian refugees and their
jordanian hosts
there are strong cultural and economic
ties between the two countries many
syrians have emigrated to jordan in the
past they've invested in local companies
and started their own businesses
but not every syrian refugee can count
on help from relatives who live in
jordan
finding a job isn't easy
and work permits are hard to come by
this is marca amman's industrial quarter
we've heard that many syrians work here
the owner of this workshop is willing to
talk to us
he knows the problems that syrian
workers have and the effect they have on
the job market
jordanian law forbids syrians from
working unless they have a permit he
says
but even so some businesses have let
jordanians go and hire syrians
on the market
he too employs syrian workers and not
just because they're cheaper
there's a big difference he says
syrians like to work
jordanians often aren't hard workers
this young syrian worked as a mechanic
before coming to jordan
he's employed here too even though he
doesn't have a work permit
not everyone would allow it he says
the young man's journey to amman wasn't
easy
he spent months living in the zatari
refugee camp near the northern border
a relative had to pay for him to be
released
now he's finally found work
it's the same story for many syrian
refugees coming to jordan means coming
to the zatari camp
we travel there to meet some of them
around 100 000 people live here in the
middle of the desert
for more than a year this u.n run
refugee camp has been the first
destination for syrians who managed to
make the dangerous journey across the
border
in the middle of the camp is a bakery
ibrahim and his family fled here from
daraa a year ago they owned a bakery
back in syria
when we arrived there was nothing but
pre-prepared food here says ibrahim
there was no bread nothing to buy
my brother said i should start baking
again
we had to smuggle in the equipment and
the cooking gas it was dangerous
we worked out of a tent when we started
we sold flatbread and falafel
now the market has developed and we run
this bakery
the business is going well
the earnings are enough to support nine
families
but it's not easy
in order to get flour and other
ingredients ibrahim has to rely on
jordanian suppliers and officials
his brother-in-law suhir is frustrated
with the situation
everyone wants bribes he says the un
people the jordanian military everyone
the whole family works in the bakery
even the children they haven't been
going to school for the past two years
despite the difficulties the family is
proud to have carved out a niche but
it's still hard for ibrahim to
contemplate the future
i have no idea he says
i don't really think about going back to
syria
the bakery is just one of many shops
that have opened on the main street of
the refugee camp it seems that many here
are not counting on going back to syria
soon
but not everyone is happy to stay many
want to start new lives outside the camp
we travel a few kilometers to the border
town of mafraq
until a year ago the town had seventy
thousand residents
now there are one hundred twenty
thousand
a beer
and her family belong to the large group
of refugees who have chosen to seek
security here
the family used to live in the zatari
camp a beer still misses her old home
and homes
our old home was different she says
imagine our kitchen was tiled
the apartment had windows and wooden
doors
it had louvered blinds
she says there's still lots of cleaning
to do
the apartment is simple but not cheap
rents have quadrupled in the past year
the family has to pay the equivalent of
190 euros per month
apartments are scarce because of the
crisis the cost puts strain on abeer's
family especially since her husband
isn't working
the family of six can't afford to spend
much on food they get basics from the
united nations
they've managed to get mattresses and a
tv
besides practical problems they're still
coming to terms with the horrors of the
war
two days before we left he says a lot of
planes came and bombed the mosque
and lots of people died
as always it's the children who suffer
most from the trauma of war
they get some relief by going to school
every afternoon ahmed and his siblings
attend a private school set up by the
charity karitas
many jordanian schools are now teaching
in the morning and afternoon to
accommodate the syrian children
the children have to get used to having
regular lessons again the teachers say
lots of them have missed months of
school because of the conflict
this teacher tells us that the children
were loud and unruly when they first
arrived
they were scared and traumatized she
says
now they like the school and when we
finish in the evening they don't want to
stop
learning one knows how long these
refugees will have to endure their
ex-island jordan
many have decided to build new lives
here
we set off back to amman
there we meet with bayan al-adawi a
syrian activist who helped found a
women's initiative called syrian kitchen
the members meet discreetly in an out of
the way house they're careful not to
attract too much attention because many
still have family in syria
in the kitchen the women bake and cook
syrian specialties
the refugees would like to set up a
catering service for jordanian clients
they say they're ready to start new
lives
they should feel as though they're
members of society says
they don't want to just wait for help to
be given to
the them kitchen project helps the women
and they realize the work they do is
worthwhile
we've had a great response especially
from our customers
the project is still in its early phases
the women already have a few jordanian
customers
they rely on word of mouth
everyone here is worried about the
future and about their families back in
syria
that's another reason they don't want
their faces shown
my relatives are spread all over says
this woman in egypt turkey lebanon and
here
my family's torn
apart it's unbelievable that bashar
al-assad is still in power
after the bloodbath after all the deaths
how can he live with himself
and how can he still be ruling syria
despite the difficulties faced by the
refugees life goes on how long they'll
be away from their homeland is
impossible to tell
but until they can return many syrians
will be staying in their adopted country
jordan